hey 42 here tell me do you see anything
unusual in this video count how many
times the players wearing white past the
basketball
you
obviously you see that as a large
gorilla suit agend randomly beating his
chest except is it in fact so obvious
this experiment is so famous at this
point that I'm willing to bet not many
people watching this video
haven't seen it and well once you've
seen it and know about the gorilla it no
longer works in this landmark experiment
from the late 90s which would go on to
win the illustrious ignoble prize two
highly eccentric researchers Christopher
Chabris and Daniel Simmons demonstrators
that roughly half of people shown this
video for the first time entirely failed
to notice two gorillas at all in fact
when told about the gorilla afterwards
people were so shocked that they usually
accused the experimenters of trickery
such as swapping over the tape after
telling them about it so how can we
explain this how can something so
blatant something right in front of our
eyes be completely overlooked well you
would be surprised how much you miss
everyday amazing things scary things new
things things that if I told you about
afterwards you would ask yourself how
the holy hell did I ever miss that well
I'm about to tell you why your brain is
actively wired to want to miss the
bleeding obvious and how it's actually
easier to completely miss totally
bizarre happenings than to see them by
the end of this video you'll learn
secrets about your brain that will
change how you see the world forever
either that or you'll go on completely
missing everything around you which
actually is much more likely but first a
quick word about today's sponsor raid
shadow legends rain shadow legends is a
new collection RPG game that is taking
the mobile and desktop gaming landscape
by storm and now the highly anticipated
battle pass is on season 1 is live and
you can win awesome awards including
free energy refills gems of graded
artifact sets and new epic and legendary
champions by fulfilling the daily and
weekly
challenges personally I love it I've
been playing the campaign mode a lot
which is super fun but can also be a
challenge you have to get just the right
combination of champions and items in
order to win it's always exciting to
open a new shard and see what new
champion or a ward you're going to get
and the new tavern mode is just
fantastic it allows you to easily
upgrade your champions and you can even
sacrifice an old champion to give your
current ones more power you can find me
in the game under the nickname 42 and if
you're quick enough you can also join my
club so what are you waiting for go to
the video description click on the
special links and if you are a new
player you will get 100,000 silver plus
50 gems but one energy refill plus one
free champion adjudicator all this
treasure will be waiting for you here
the user wards will only be available
for new players for the next 30 days so
don't delay
good luck and I'll see you there we're
constantly being told to feel is a more
attention to the wonders of the evolving
world around us but while all that seems
a fine idea in principle experiments
like this guerrilla grift demonstrates
an uncomfortable fact seeing what's in
front of us isn't as straightforward as
it sounds and there's ample reason to
think that it simply isn't possible
according to science it isn't your fault
if you don't notice the inherent beauty
of every shrub or sunset turns out
that's just how the brain works if you
often miss the obvious you're not alone
even people who are paid enormous
salaries who spot or expected
inconsistencies often fail miserably to
do so and in a very public way every
Hollywood movie on primetime TV or
Netflix series has a person whose sole
job is to ensure continuity throughout
the production a single scene can be
shot over multiple days or even weeks so
it's important to maintain continuity
between shoots eg coffee cups shouldn't
move around between multiple cuts and
there shouldn't be objects that are
historically inaccurate in a
such as an iPhone in a film set in the
50s the person whose job this is is
called the script supervisor it's an
essential job that is fairly well paid
because without a good script supervisor
on set a film that has a budget of over
fifty million dollars couldn't like a
total amateur shitshow and all because
of some really basic blunders but script
supervisors mess up a lot in fact almost
every large budget film or TV show in
the past 50 years has at least one
continuity error in it somewhere
there are whole websites dedicated to
finding and documenting them some famous
continuity errors include in the Lord of
the Rings the Fellowship of the Ring a
car can be spotted in the distant
background casually driving around
middle-earth in Pulp Fiction when
Vincent and Jules miraculously dodged
the bullets from the guy hiding behind
the door the bullet holes magically
appear in the wall behind them before he
actually shoots at them I'm sure you
know of the infamous stormtrooper in
Star Wars Episode four who hits his head
in The Wizard of Oz Dorothy's her
repeatedly changes lengths between
scenes such errors have colloquially
come to be referred to as film flops and
this is a small selection of thousands
but how could the script supervisors not
notice these flops how could the large
post-production teams not notice them in
the editing suite
how could quality control not notice
time during pre screening sessions yet
to the casual viewer they can often jump
out from the screen to understand why
you missed a gorilla and why top film
producers miss a Starbucks cup on the
set of a medieval tavern we need to look
more closely at how our perceptions are
formed and what you'll discover will
change how you perceive vision forever
whilst estimates vary it's generally
accepted that the human brain processes
around 11 million bits of sensory
information every second yet it only
makes us conscious of between 40
120 bits that's a lot of information
processing the vast vast majority of
which we aren't even consciously aware
of the reasons for the brain to filter
information in this way are numerous but
most clearly it does it because being
aware of every single piece of
information your brain receives every
photon of light every individual grain
of sand has basically zero practical
utility it won't help you to survive or
procreate and it would be incredibly
inefficient for you to sift through
every piece of data available before
making a simple decision or evaluating a
situation if you did it would take you a
day to make a cup of coffee instead of
five minutes because even during this
simple task the amount of information
your brain could process if it wanted to
is unfathomably huge because it has so
much information to sort through in such
short periods of time our brains always
tend towards the most efficient easiest
way of doing things
this seems fair after all the brain is
fundamentally a biological entity
operating on limited energy sources just
like the rest of our body like a river
carving its way down a mountain your
brain will always choose the path of
least resistance so to save energy and
be efficient
our brains build what are known as
predictive models this is a fairly
recent theory of how the brain works and
it can seem utterly bizarre at first but
the notion of the brain is essentially a
prediction machine makes an awful lot of
sense when you actually own pockets the
theory goes something like this rather
than as we tend to assume receiving
information about our surroundings
through our sensors and then responding
to that information our brain approaches
our surroundings with a pre-existing
prediction as to what they should
contain such as a forest should contain
trees and a face should have a nose then
it adjusts those predictions based on
the actual information it receives your
brain builds millions of these
predictive models as you progress
throughout your life and they range from
general to really specific your brain
probably has a model that predicts when
you open it'll provide scream there will
be ice cream inside it the input to the
model is an unopened ice cream top of
the lid being removed the two outputs
are ice cream or an empty top because
I'm willing to bet 100% of the time that
is what you see when you open the top of
ice cream and if you see something else
then you need a refund so your brain
doesn't use its limited energy resources
to analyze the color and shape of the
contents of the top every time it's
opened and then calculate that what it's
seeing is in fact ice cream instead it
builds a predictive model that knows to
always expect either ice cream or
nothing this model is usually built
during your childhood unless you had a
severely unhappy or bringing your brain
based on past experiences presumes a
familiar meaningful order will be found
everywhere and that's because most of
the time it is this is why we experience
a phenomenon known as pareidolia where
we see faces are Nova recognizable
images in inanimate objects when the
goal is saving time and energy it seems
a no-brainer to leverage one's existing
experiences to make informed guesses
particularly when they're more than
often correct so much of the world
behaves mechanistically obeys fairly
tight intuitive laws of physics and
nature so when the brain realizes that
99% of our daily life and the
environments around us are fundamentally
unchanging it's a futile waste of energy
to ponder whether some wild anomaly is
about to occur of course the floor could
collapse underneath you when you get out
of bed it's just not worth spending time
and energy considering it however there
are clearly instances when our brains
predictions get things very wrong the
jokes often uses predictive mechanism to
mess with us they evoke a familiar
pattern when I was younger I
like a man trapped inside a woman's body
before subverting it in a surprising way
then I was born the predictive brain
theory helps explain why for example you
often seem to hear people saying your
name in the street why priming you with
a high number will get you to
overestimate the price of a product and
as will shortly sit by 50% of people
managed to entirely miss a gorilla
suitors chest-beating mark in the middle
of the game of basketball now common
sense would have it that the sheer
novelty of a gorilla walking through the
screen would shock and arouse our
attention but there are two distinct
factors at play here
which explains why most people do miss
the gorilla firstly the experimenters
gave to participants something specific
to focus on they were asked to count the
number of passes of the ball this
provided ample destruction from the
gorilla but the second and more
impactful factor is that the
participants brains had constructed
predictive models about what happens
when a bunch of people pass a ball
around and not one of those models
unless they had seen this video before
which they hadn't contained an outcome
which includes a gorilla walking through
the group the brain is adept at
filtering out any outcomes that don't
neatly fit into its usual predictive
models unless it presents an immediate
danger it prefers to ignore the out of
place than to waste energy actively
focusing on and deciphering it this is
also why script supervisors and so many
other industry professionals working on
the same film failed to notice rather
obvious film flops the things that are
out of place are usually not a part of
their predictive models you have to
become highly specialized in noticing
specific things before your brain builds
it into its models and hence begins to
notice them automatically
for example people have repeated to
gorilla experiment and found that
individuals who work in zoos almost
always spot the gorilla the first time
they watch to take why because such
people have been repeatedly exposed to
gorillas so it's only natural a lot of
brain builds girl
Ehlers into its models because it learns
to expect to regularly see them it's
also been discovered that when people
are told to look out for a gorilla the
day before watching the video for the
first time they usually still fail to
see it because your expectations reset
on a daily basis your brain only adapts
its predictive models if you are told to
expect to see a gorilla or actually see
one almost every day like the zoo
workers this is evidenced by the odd
facts that cities that have a larger
quantity of cyclist have much much lower
cycle accident rates than cities with
fewer cycles why because drivers who
live in those cities see bicycles so
regularly in large numbers that their
brains have firmly embedded them into
their predictive models and because they
expect to see cyclist everywhere on the
roads they will consequently drive more
carefully around them similarly you only
become aware of the fact that your brain
uses these predictive models on the rare
instances that they are wrong your brain
has developed a model for how to walk up
and down stairs it is because of this
model like you don't have to actively
think about the exact force and fine
motor control required to complete what
is actually a rather complex set of
movements but when it goes wrong
suddenly your autopilot mode switches
off when you take a step and there is an
unexpected gap of an object you trip or
stumble and because this movement
doesn't fit into your brains predictive
model for traversing stairs your brain
suddenly stops being lazy for a moment
and snaps into active focus mode and you
[ __ ] yourself as that awful falling
feeling surges through your body you've
probably noticed that after many months
of driving you start driving on
autopilot you no longer have to focus on
changing gears and steering around
corners you just do it subconsciously
you can drive for hours over vast
distances and
totally zone out until BAM you have a
crash and because that wasn't a part of
your usual predictive models for driving
a vehicle your brain wasn't expecting it
to happen always not actively searching
for it this is a part of the reason why
braking distances are so much longer for
a human behind the wheel than a computer
the predictive models your brain builds
for activities such as prolonged driving
are actually visible as physical
structures on MRI scans when
neuroscience is first discovered them in
the 90s they named them diem ends
default mode networks you have one for
tying your shoelaces brushing your teeth
and riding a bike and diem ends can be
leveraged for some rather funny and
unbelievable experiments
Daniel Simmons one half of the team
behind the original gorilla experiment
tested this out in another famous
experiment in 1998 strangers were asked
for directions but mid-conversation
people would walk in between them
carrying a door during which the
experimenter the one asking for
directions would be swapped out for a
completely different person amazingly it
didn't matter if the person swapped out
looked completely different 50% of the
time people failed to notice that they
were now talking to someone else this
phenomenon is called change blindness
because of predictive models the human
brain is terrible at noticing changes in
our surroundings both subtle and
seemingly obvious this is why movie
flops are notoriously ubiquitous even
when millions are spent to ensure flops
don't occur they inevitably do because
of change blindness everyone suffers
from it
it's a part of life amazingly this
experiment has also been repeated with a
receptionist swapping with another
person after ducking behind desk for a
second surely people would notice to
change when looking directly at the
person they are talking to nope still
50% of people fail to notice the swap
incredibly this still remains true when
the person be
the desk changes gender mid-conversation
why don't people notice the swap because
after hundreds of conversations for
people behind desks our brains have
learned not to expect people to suddenly
change and on a basic level this is how
your brain functions and observes the
world around you thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video then please
consider supporting me on patreon using
the link in the description it really
helps me out to continue making these
videos and don't forget to check out the
sponsor rage Shadow legends